[Music]
ladies and gentlemen let's face it this
time of year can be a little depressing
for some people but well one person has
been having a particularly rough time
the last few weeks and I thought we'd
talk to him about it
so please welcome via satellite this is
expensive for us God God
[Applause]
tell us God where are you I don't know
some dive it doesn't matter now you seem
really depressed God what's wrong tell
us oh girl I start first of all you see
no my boy Tim Tebow's been playing
lately yeah he had lost his last three
games yeah yeah Barbara Walters could
throw a tighter spiral than that
kiss-ass choirboy
hey anything else bothering you god yeah
Michele Bachmann totally tanked in Iowa
that's that's true she said that you
personally told her to run for president
yeah I thought America was ready for a
nutjob president with a husband that's a
little light in the loafers you heard
him people trust me folks it would have
been fun especially that war with
Australia yeah all right that's what you
want all right okay what else has got
you down there God I thought everybody
go for that new Chipmunks movie
chipwrecked yeah that movie chips suck
yeah all right
clever God had a little time to work
yeah shut up
let's cheer up just so God
I had it coming he's so drunk he doesn't
care
cheer up God you still have a lot to be
proud of yeah like what Christian rock
it's still blows give it time no we
don't have any time
the Mayans are still bugging me to shut
the whole thing down this year all right
let's go bars closed dude go anywhere oh
my god you gotta go just go
[Applause]
Oh
[Applause]